who's gonna build the cities of tomorrow
will it be human workers or machines why
not both I'm Grant Imahara
along with wired brand lab and Mouser
I'm traveling the world exploring the
ways people and companies are using
innovative technologies and shaping
Smarter Cities it's back home to Los
Angeles a city I know very well yet I
had no idea that it's home to one of the
leading augmented reality companies in
the world at daiquiri we make augmented
reality hardware and software to solve
some of the most challenging
environments
that's a are put to work in industrial
and enterprise and automotive
applications cities are an example of
how much information there is in the
background and what AR is really good at
is taking that information and making it
visible so how about a city project like
a bridge or a transportation center
freeway or even a giant skyscraper that
you're trying to build how can a our
help in those situations AR can help in
all those cases you can take a 3d model
of your skyscraper and visualize it at
true scale so now you can explore it and
see what it's like even before you build
it most cities they have construction
they have power and water and utilities
of all kinds and all of those services
rely on data as the pulse of how they
operate augmented reality is allowing
them to get that out of the servers and
into the hands of the workers that need
to make decisions what types of
information could you overlay over an
image say a worker goes into a job site
what could you show them so a really
common use today is in construction
sites you're taking your 3d models and
combining it with real-time information
whether that's construction schedules
and critical paths or actual operational
data anything that you've got data for
whether it's the pipes running under the
road the cables we can pop the helmet on
and visualize things see
they're running and we can visualize our
new buildings overlaid on top of that as
well so being able to have a model
that's geospatially located being able
to put on a helmet from any viewpoint
and look at what the impact will be is
something that would be important they
are is fundamental to the work of the
future you could be servicing a car
today and a jet engine tomorrow it
really has this potential to transform
workers and elevate their skill levels
so we really think that it's going to be
augmented reality everywhere it won't
matter what your job is air will touch
it in some way as knackery visualizes
the future they're incorporating
components from around the world and
Mauser suppliers like analog devices
Intel microchip technology and molex are
leading the way with products that make
global innovation possible I've been
lucky enough to travel the world to take
a closer look at how are shaping Smarter
Cities I think it's time to head back to
where this journey began
wired brand lab take inventory of
everything I've learned